welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and loki gave
us six episodes packed with hidden
easter eggs most of which i thought i
found in our exhaustive breakdowns but
uh
wake up from that hibernation winter
soldier boss there are at least
30 more insane details to hunt down in a
full season re-watch and the
behind-the-scenes documentary assembled
you gotta check that out it's full of
great stuff
i'm gonna break it all down for you from
the nerdy secrets on the blackboard and
the citadel to the horny secrets on the
whiteboard in the writers room
you thought i'd forget about the shots i
missed but i remember
all of them let's rewind back to episode
one loki crash lands of the gobi desert
and the clothes the mongolians wear
actually get reused later in the series
because jonathan major's revealed he who
remains closed
are a collage of different settings and
time periods to reflect his experiences
including
every piece we decided was from a
different place
the cape i had on was from the victoria
era the shoes are from
genghis khan the the pants from mongolia
etc
yes so the pants of loki's ultimate
enemy are literally hidden behind the
curtain of this mongolian's outerwear
the designers said that the time doors
were visually inspired by the
translucent blocky design of the shields
and david lynch's dune
not to be confused with the dannyville
new version that's coming out later this
year a little less tetrissy and the
purple
smoke in the reset charges was likely to
ride from the purple smoke of goliath
whose void
these pruned things gets sent to hunter
b-15 has scratch marks on her helmet
tallying her pruning so badass but
notice how all of the chrono monitors
uniforms have black and burnt orange
parts that interchange from soldier to
soldier which the costumer called their
harlequin design to reflect the rubik's
cube like interchangeability of time
in this show the production designers
built the tva with an
inner class system they said reflected
in the types of workers in their
uniforms and in the structural layout of
the building
on the bottom level is security home to
starkly dressed officers
the middle level as management home to
the plainly dressed clerks and agents
and the top level is legal home to more
sharply dressed judges with their fancy
sashes
the stanchion room was deliberately
designed with overhead lamps with
tipped light bulbs so that it would look
like countless eyes staring down at you
like the eyes of the tva agents and the
variant kangs watching your every move
if you look at it it looks like a sea of
eyeballs essentially
see when i point out these eye shapes in
the set design folks i'm not
bullshitting you the set designers are
the same big brother
and paranoia that i have bts documentary
actually showed concept art of this room
that included a variant rocket
meaning that was one rejected concept
concept art of president loki's bandit
gang
also includes a kitty cat variant but
the most interesting bts photo i saw
shows head writer michael waldron in the
writer's room
outlining episode one now on that
whiteboard is a circle
this is the story circle developed by
dan harmon whom waldren previously
worked with on rick and morty harmon
derived this from joseph campbell's
monomyth as a way to force characters to
break past
simple a to b stories you see in tv
writing to more cathartic cyclical
journeys in which they evolve past what
they thought they wanted
to truly change the circle has eight
steps you
need go search find take return and
change
and if you slide over the left you can
see one proposed eight step story for
episode one that was clearly changed one
loki visiting different time periods two
doing crazy mischief aka sex three
pivots to taking power
four collecting infinity stones five has
the gauntlet holds power
more sex by alien etc six alone in the
throne room he's taken power but
is inflected with the thoughts that it
isn't real because the tva's control of
a free will
seven returns to the tva gauntlets power
down mobius is waiting for him
eight loki gives honest answers to
mobius
mobius
shows the sheer power of the tva so one
original plan for episode 1 was for loki
to go on more of a sexcapade and follow
in thanos footsteps and achieve the full
infinity gauntlet but like in that fifth
fine step what you think you wanted
isn't really what you really need so
then moving on to the sixth take step of
beginning to pay an emotional price for
that of his existential crisis
leading to return to the tva with a
whole depowered gauntlet instead of just
a tesseract but still with a very
cathartic ending similar to the one we
actually got in episode one also in this
episode loki threatens casey give me the
tesseract or i'll gut you like a fish
casey which you could see is an odd to
the character casey in the scream
opening scene you hang up on me again
i'll cut you like a
fish and in the scene where loki sees
his own death on the film notice how the
tape plays several seconds
after his actual neck snap meaning that
version of loki might have actually felt
thor hugging his broken body and then in
the final scene the oil field the shovel
that silvi uses to lure them there if
you look closely at their tin pad this
is a quantum ore
shovel manufactured by advanced idea
mechanics
the company of aldridge killian in iron
man 3 and perhaps a link to
modoc's coming arrival in the mcu and in
the credits of each episode
the poster on the locker changes episode
episode episode 1
always watching it's an episode about
loki learning that all of his actions
are being watched episode 2
less me needs more productivity the
timeline demands it get me this poster
and this is an episode about loki
bristling against the clerical duties of
the tva episode three the timeline is
only as strong as its weakest moment an
episode that leaves loki at his weakest
moment on the doomed planet of lamentus
one
episode four hunters for an episode that
definitely softens and characterizes
mobius and the hunter b15 episode 5
nexus events must be pruned
an episode about each variant's nexus
event in episode 6 stable society tidy
timeline in which he who remains tries
to justify his actions to
stabilize the timeline also changing an
episode episode in the credits are the
cast photos under the casting director
credit episode 1
loki in his various forms including db
cooper episode 2
loki as a tva agent and hooded soviet
episode 3 sylvia and loki together on
lament 1 episode 4
young sylvie sylvian b-15 and sylvian
loki's nexus event
episode 5 the new loki variants we meet
in the void in episode 6 some that we've
seen before but now including loki
sitting sadly in the time theater but
over all of these there is a hand
in the corner sliding around on the
table this could be the hand of he who
remains
rifling through the various loki's as he
reviews his script prior to the big
meeting in episode six by the way after
a long day trying to find all this stuff
i like to kick back with a nice glass of
wine but the problem is i'm no expert
and i don't know that i'm gonna be an
expert anytime soon well lucky for me
there is bright sellers they use a quiz
to determine your taste preferences and
then they show you a list of the top six
wines that you're most likely to enjoy
from around the world
and they educate you about wine along
the way to help you find your new
favorites and if you like your
recommendations and want to try them
they'll ship them straight to your door
each bottle comes with an educational
card with tips about serving and pairing
let's see what's in the box this time
ooh we got a silverscape wine it says
it's leading
with powerful aromas of dark fruits like
blackberry blackcurrant boysenberry
we also got a crypsis and the tails from
the crypsis are this is an elegant red
with beautiful ruby color and aromas of
plum
raspberry and blackberry you know i
think i'll start with this one and then
like finish with this one it's gonna be
a fun night
i've actually got a few boxes from
bright sellers and based on my ratings
they sent me these new wines and i'm so
grateful
brightsellers is giving our followers 60
off their first four bottle box that's
an amazing deal so follow the link and
take the quiz and get started but on
episode two after mobius says that he
expected loki to stab in the back i like
how later in the episode in the rocks
cart store
he refuses to let loki walk behind him
in episode 3 the mining town of lamentus
1 was decorated with cyrillic letters
including
rip yet that's the town where chernobyl
occurred and nkvd
the soviet interior ministry reversed
just as a way of evoking the whole
abandoned feel of this industrial town
and while i speculated that sign and
alien lettering on the building that
sylvie checks might translate to
pre-rack
using that one two three two three four
substitution code it actually more
likely translates to
mining in episode four the voices of the
timekeeper androids were done by
jonathan magers
which explains why in those episode
credits no one was credited for those
characters only the onset readers before
major's audio was dubbed in because they
didn't want to spoil it now in episode 5
i thought i found most of the stuff in
the void but there was this bus
near loki in the opening shot which has
the name callum ross and i swear to god
i did find this
but i was like why is a toronto area
mortgage broker important to the mcu but
actually calum ross is also the name of
an editor who works on the loki series
the voice
of throg grunting is actually chris
hemsworth's audio
and in episode 6 i got nearly all of the
mcu audio clips in the intro which was
really hard because most of them
actually were not in the closed captions
but there was one additional one shuri
from black panther
another broken white boy for us to fix
there's also way
more music in this mix than the ones i
pointed out it's been a long long time
tchaikovsky swan lake and beethoven's
fear release for the sake of old lang
zine
i can say by pat thomas
[Music]
i put a spell on you by nina simone
put a spell on you a bollywood song swag
saha nahi j
by sonic shishina
[Music]
in an 80s hit i should be so lucky by
kylie minogue
now the citadel's kitsugi looking design
was according to the director not
intended to be broken shards of the
multiverse reassembled
but really the whole citadel carved out
from that asteroid that itself had these
streaks inside of it now on the floor
the inner chamber is a latin phrase
omnia tempus and m semper aka for all
time always meanwhile the production
designer said that mysterious broken
fourth time paper statue which i
speculated could be the fourth time
keeper from the comics the banished
oracle asiwa all they said is that
answers will be forthcoming
now in the elevator he remains says
don't tell me i'm a disappointment
and as he says says jonathan majors
looks directly into the camera making
this a meta message to the viewer as
well like if i don't mean your
expectations
i don't want to hear it now i pointed
out that chalkboard calculus integral
equations but since then i've learned
exactly what these are
this is the first part of the non-linear
integration equation
used by quantum theorists to try to
understand non-commutativity aka the
order of elements in a mathematical
equation and whether or not they're
interchangeable or non-linear it
actually in a way echoes alan watts
philosophy that we heard at the
beginning of the episode which talked
about time and how we assumed
only moved in one direction past cause
the present could actually be
variable and fluid and interchangeable
and finally by now you may have seen
folks sinking the loki finale with
wandavision's finale to show how the
moment juan maximoff powers up into the
scarlet witch and allows agave to thunk
on the ground
sinks almost exactly with he remains
dropping an object on his desk to test
if the sacred timeline has indeed broken
it's an interesting connection i went
into my thoughts on inside marvel but as
for what he who remains is actually
doing by dropping this object i'm
thinking it may be a nod to dr ian
malcolm's explanation of chaos theory
and non-linear equations in jurassic
park when he dropped water on laura
durn's hand to see which way the drop
would roll each time the change
why because tiny variations
can never repeat and vastly affect the
outcome
that's important unpredictability see
here i'm now by myself
talking to myself that's that's chaos
there yes borrowing from other eccentric
famous loners like willy wonka i'm
willing to bet majors improvise this
moment as a way of showing how he
remains
who scribbles the exact kind of
equations dr ian malcolm would on that
blackboard is checking to see
not how the object fell according to
gravity but how it landed on the table
now for everything else hidden in the
show feel free to re-watch our six
episode breakdowns
in-depth work i'm very proud of the
whole new rockstars team for if i didn't
mention something here it's probably in
one of those videos so if you are down
in the comments and you're about to
write one of these that we've already
mentioned or if you see someone else
writing something we already mentioned
on this or any other video you have my
permission to reply in all caps
boss already covered this follow me on
twitter and instagram
eavos follow new rockstars and subscribe
to new rockstars for breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you